you saw what happened with china right
china declares all cryptocurrency
transactions illegal you saw bitcoin
took a hit ethereum took a hit everybody
took a hit
uh with that so uh china central bank
has announced that all transactions of
cryptocurrencies are illegal effectively
banning digital tokens such as bitcoin
fluctuations there often impact the
global price of cryptocurrencies and the
price of bitcoin fell by more than 2 000
in a wake of chinese announcements it is
the latest in china's national crackdown
on what is
what it sees as a volatile speculative
investment at best and a way to launder
money at worst trading cryptocurrencies
has officially been banned in china
since 2019 but has continued online
foreign exchanges but last week's
announcement is the clearest indication
yet that china wants to shut down
cryptocurrencies trading in all its
forms is what they want to do so
barry is um
barry's not a debate no he's got a track
record and people thought he was crazy
when he said that the housing market was
going to crash i think when you have
that much credibility and you just look
at the evidence when you look at
inflation you look at the situation in
china with evergrande the debt ceiling
inflation global shipping shortage i
mean there's just so many things that
are stacked up against the stock market
continuing to boom
and china at the same time they're
showing their cards they're also kind of
telling the world look you know here's
the direction we're going if you there
was a girl that was a star social media
star with like 40 50 million followers
overnight she disappeared like what the
hell happened to her like a huge star
the guy that was worth 38 billion
dollars overnight his 38 billion dollars
is gone jack ma says one thing in front
of a
you know talking against china hey
when's the last time you saw jack ma
doing an interview with cnbc or msnbc or
anything that was a year ago and that
was a year ago you talked about on rogan
about capitalism and communism and about
lifting up individuals but also like the
team the collective and that's kind of
what china's doing is they don't want
superstars they don't want superstars
yeah and this is shining a spotlight on
basically what china wants they want to
um they want control they want to you
know have regulation all over crypto but
something that we're not talking about
is because they're banning crypto and
banning bitcoin
part of the reason is they want to
develop their own digital wand and and
do all that so they
they you know we talked about the social
score on rogan you talked about that
china is basically trying to control
your whole life and they don't want
superstars that's why the people like
jack ma
you know yeah they go to re-education
camps well we we talked about it on the
last podcast guys that um you know
where's the epicenter of power in
america it used to be new york he used
to be dc maybe la it's it's all san
francisco now all tech right we talked
about it and he's betting against
america not once twice he's saying
treasury bonds are going down that's
betting against america you're betting
the country is is about to be in big bad
shape but you're betting on facebook and
google so if america is going down but
tech is going up i think that that kind
of tells you where where the power
within tech really lies and we we talk
not to get too crazy with it guys but i
mean if anybody out there wants to spend
the rest of their day going down a fun
rabbit hole check out the frankfurt
school check out what critical theory is
we hear a lot about critical race theory
today critical race theory is the latest
incarnation of something called critical
theory critical theory was a way that
hegelians and marxists decided that they
would try to implement communism in
society and basically you have to break
the wheel in order in order to implement
a communist revolution all right
worldwide communist revolution now i'm
not saying this is what's happening i'm
just saying if you want to do some fun
reading okay antonio gramsci who the
president of ireland just stopped and
paid respects to at his grave on the way
this is not a good man here
you know antonio graham's not not a good
man i don't know what kind of a man he
was his philosophy is very dangerous so
in order to bring in a global communist
revolution you have to break the wheel
all right in times of prosperity nobody
wants revolution so in order for them if
you believe in and build back better if
you believe in a future where you will
own nothing and be happy
uh in order for that to happen a crash
is is is absolutely necessary they talk
about it at length at the frankfurt
school to talk about cultural hegemony
this is guys if you've studied kind of
you know political theory if you've if
you've studied this stuff a lot of this
is like you're seeing a slow-motion
train wreck
it's it's kind of nuts but just enjoy
check out the frankfurt school i think
you guys will get some value and some
payment out of that even if there is
this crash
that there's a crash so how many crashes
have we experienced time
so not a time let's say 10.
boom i'm saying in the last 20 years dot
com boom lasted a year or so 2008 lasted
a couple years
20 i mean covet lasted like six months
as far as the the market goes
so
it's gonna crash it's crashed the
housing crash the market crash
if you're young and you're in the stock
market and you have crypto is are you
really that worried there's one thing
more older people did i tell you one
thing concerns me here's what concerns
me i agree you know how it's like
it's cyclical it happens it's cyclical
it happens this is no different it's
cyclical it happens this is no different
it's cyclical it happens right okay fine
let's say it is only cyclical and it
happens there's one thing that's not
normal
um
40 plus percent of the currency was
printed last 18 months right that's a
lot of money was sent free to people bro
we've not sent like money like that to
people we're just people are sitting on
the sidelines saying no if you pay me
this i'll come and companies like [ __ ]
this guy's only worth
18 bucks an hour at best i have to pay
this guy 28 bucks to come back to work
what the hell do i do
okay i'll give you 28 bucks okay and you
better not let me go out 458 and then
it's like a very weird dynamic that's
going on today right like
employers are begging and this is what
they want employers are begging people
to come back to work and people say no
i'm good man i'm playing video games i'm
chilling i'm playing netflix so how long
when that goes do you get the person
want to come back and really give their
best i don't know so that's one thing
that leads to fake success now they're
talking another three and a half
trillion dollars
which i don't know if you've looked at
what's in the three and a half trillion
dollars again a bunch of other [ __ ]
that they've added to the three and a
half three and a half trillion dollars
well the senate just struck it down and
you saw what biden just said you know
what biden just said with the money when
no americans are not going to pay for it
this is not going to go to the death
effort this is not going to go to our
deficit it will not pay anything for it
it's going to pay for itself pelosi is
saying it's going to pay for itself it's
going to pay for its sales job right and
you know what she said again here's what
she said look let's just pass it so we
can find out what's in it same line
she's used oh my god in the past before
this is not a new thing that these guys
are doing so are you saying that and i
gave you three examples 2001 2008 2020
that this potential crash would be worse
than that but go to each one go to each
one yeah what is a one oh one was just
you know
dot com boom i bought no no oh one oh
one what you're talking about 911
talking about no well it was 99 yeah 99
2000 2001 all that free money yeah
private equity got into the game okay
and they started putting money to people
that really didn't have the best idea
and it was just like it flapped just as
long as that dot com behind it yeah and
then
that was the market and then obviously
911 so it was a lot of fake money there
but it was created by who
the market created fake money okay in
98.99 the more over evaluating companies
that's right the market so that's cool
if the market creates fake success guess
what you're going to take you're going
to lose billions and you're going to
have to come back and treat it in
different ways that's a correction go to
osa that's a correction go to o7 what
was what was the deal with 07. housing
housing a program comes from australia
called no income no ass it's nina okay
where it's a pick a payment and
everybody's buying a million dollar
house michael murray everything that's
right and the big short and then what
happens there fake success
more fake success who takes a hit a 330
billion dollar company called wamu gets
bought by a chase for 1.9 billion
dollars
there were some victims bear stearns had
to go down sure um but who else okay
well that's a lot about there's a lot a
lot of victims i mean country-wide you
forget countrywide it was like all over
the place fremont invested it's a little
big mortgage so but then you go to today
so you said oh one right 08 today today
2020 exactly well 2020 is a co kobe
because if kobe doesn't hit trump's
getting re-elected the economy was doing
great people were working people were
talking just talk about the median
income had increased for the first time
in 20 years it had increased to 60 000
from 55 000 under his watch unemployment
for everybody was fine
record low blacks hispanics women in
every way everything was good china was
having to kind of change back and kind
of see what they're going to do with u.s
you know isis you didn't hear a single
thing about isis all that stuff sweets
pat but but but i will tell you though
there's a part of that that he he is his
own enemy there's there's nobody that's
a bigger enemy than himself on what he
did but his his policies very effective
policies then covet shows up
kobe becomes a great opportunity to do
what
impose any ideas that you want we could
have been united and the enemy would
have been china but no instead of
creating the enemy because like right
now let's just say uh uh let's just say
something happens in this building okay
and the building uh uh is on fire okay
when a building's on fire there's a
couple things the building could do like
remember that one day the car was on
fire everybody's running i'm on a board
call they're telling me pat you got to
go downstairs all this other stuff i
don't remember this was like four weeks
ago
okay told me not to come in that day
so guess what happened wait they tell
you not to come in every day
watch what happens that day
what happened that day when they told us
it's a fire do you actually remember no
we're go oh you weren't here so we ran
downstairs we're holding doors for each
other come on folks let's go come on
let's go too because the enemy was what
the fire right makes sense now imagine
if somebody said
he did it it's his fault this guy did it
he's doing it it's because of him and
we're like who him hi
so so the point is
rather than using covet to unify america
the left saw this and say perfect
opportunity to make trump the villain
ding ding ding ding ding you win he's
out but the reality was china caused the
great divorce
china is the one that caused the fire
that's the challenge that we have and
now fast forward to today you give all
this money to people for a while and you
get employers to go against employ
everything right now is against against
employers against employees
men against women parents against kids
okay republicans against democrats
against citizens police against versus
a church going against and
everything is against adam versus gerard
let's go you know it is my birthday that
constant against is what's causing us to
be yeah and it's becoming the new normal
which is what's which is what they want
and which is really really so this is a
very different thing so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast click over here take
care everybody bye
[Music]